if you love shits Creek and are very sad
it has come to an end here are five
other shows or movies totally worth
checking out on this week's binge guide
what's up guys Nazz here coming at you
from my couch and with the surprise hit
turned emmy-nominated show shits Creek
coming to an end this week all we can
say is ill David so if your bum shits
creeks over just like I am here's what
you can watch next starting with our
certified fresh pick Parks and
Recreation this mockumentary about a
Parks and Rec Department helped launch
the career of a certain star Lord and
after struggling with ratings in the
shadow of the office it's gotten a
second wind now thanks to Netflix shits
Creek fans will love it for the small
town aspect and probably for the same
reason critics loved it over the years
as they've called it heartfelt yet
hilarious and snarky yet good nature
that's also on my tinder profile you can
get through all 125 episodes in just
under 46 hours and it'll make you wish
you spent even longer in good ole Pawnee
Indiana up next is our under-the-radar
pic and that's happy endings
a Chicago set sitcom following the lives
of six young urbanites trying to figure
out the ropes of adulthood aren't we all
much like sheds this one has a great
ensemble cast that includes hilarious
performances from people like Casey
Wilson Damon Wayans Jr Adam pally and
Elisha Cuthbert critics have called it
thoroughly silly yet consistently funny
with only three seasons getting through
this one will take you about 21 hours
and it's even better if you watch it
with your closest friends just not in
the same room or six feet apart coming
in with our brand new pig is the Apple
TV Plus show mythic quest Ravens banquet
this one centers around a team of video
game developers attempting to run a
popular video game similar to shits
Creek this show features all kinds of
people from different walks of life
trying to coexist in the same space and
as the critics have said it stands out
for exploring the gaming industry with
intelligence thoughtfulness and
sincerity this half-hour show only has 9
episodes so far make it a fun and really
easy bench even if you don't play or
know anything about video games and for
our throwback pick this week we're gonna
head back
20 years to the certified fresh' film
best-in-show a hilarious comedy about
the cutthroat world of dog shows critics
love it because of its appealing quirky
premise and brilliantly talented cast
which of course includes shits Creek
Eugene Levy and his eyebrows and
Catherine O'Hara doing some of their
finest and funniest work the 90-minute
Best in Show is an easy watch so if you
want other Christopher Guest film
starring these to check out waiting for
Guffman a mighty wind and for your
consideration and finally for our
editor's pick we think as we're checking
out Arrested Development just like shits
Creek this show hilariously follows a
family dealing with life after financial
ruin not only did it revive Jason
Bateman's career but Arrested
Development also help make household
names out of people like Michael Cera
and Will Arnett and the critics called
it a brilliantly fast-paced anon
dysfunctional family comedy there are
just five seasons the final two seasons
actually came thirteen years after the
first three and it'll only take about 31
hours to get through them all and it is
well worth your time alright guys
hopefully this will help get you through
your next to binge sessions be sure to
check back for more recommendations and
ideas based around the shows that you
love right here on the Rotten Tomatoes
binge guide I'll be right here
[Music]